saying goodbye our series changing the
game Highlights Highlights rather
extraordinary women and for Black
History Month we are highlighting black
women making a difference in their
fields yes yes yes and now for our
future Generations sneakers are a
multi-billion dollar industry I bet you
know that and Jennifer Ford remember
this name is the only black female
founder of a sneaker retailer in the U.S
how is that possible she owns premium
Goods in Houston after 20 years in the
business Jennifer was recently invited
to design two new Air Force Ones for
Nike that's a big deal that's a big deal
the collaboration marks the first time
Nike has collaborated with a woman's
retailer on new designs and we are very
proud to say Jennifer Ford is in the
house with us this morning welcome in
Bravo congratulations thank you so much
sneakers are to me seem to be having a
moment you can wear them with ball gowns
you can wear them with jeans you can
wear them with dresses wear them to work
where did your love start and how uh
well my love for sneakers probably
started when I was in junior high in
high school when like Jordans came out
but it really made sense to me more so
after college when I can afford to buy
them so I lived in New York at the time
and the late
um late 90s early 2000s and when Sneaker
boutiques were starting to open here and
you would see them in the west coast a
little bit in Chicago but we didn't have
anything in my city at the time yeah I
know but a lot of women myself included
would go to work in sneakers and then
change when you get to work put on your
real work shoes did you do that oh
totally that was uh that was my thing
it's like walking the streets of New
York you don't want to walk around the
hills and I worked for a company that
required you to wear pantyhose and heels
to work very uncomfortable not the
Practical thing in the subway so that's
totally my thing to take them into work
and then change after the thing about
sneakers now is you can you can wear
them in all those different uh settings
but you can also not wear them they're
like works of art right people collect
them they put them on a shelf it looks
like a store in their house Nate's got a
whole like yeah
so talk to us about what you've designed
here your two sneakers your two Air
Force Ones uh
opportunity to
um based off my career at Lord Taylor I
used to be a jewelry buyer and uh it
just made sense to me I love jewelry and
accessories and I wanted to create
something that was
um beautiful but that you could wear I
believe people should wear their
sneakers they're comfortable uh there
are tons of them if you're buying it
enjoy it feel good in them so I wanted
to create something that I could wear
and that would mean something to me and
as they um as they developed
they just made that both made sense to
uh give name them after my daughter and
my my niece just I got 30 seconds for
this question your inspiration to girls
watching who see you and want to be you
oh
um so it's uh being the only black
female in the industry and being one of
the few that are in the industry um it
seems like um it's not a uh easy career
to get into
um but it's it's been a great journey
everyone's been uh super amazing through
it and I just want girls uh watching and
women watching to believe in themselves
and uh to follow their dreams but did
you think this could be a business for
you a successful business did you think
that I
six when I opened my Boutique and I
thought I could take on the world I had
just left New York and I was going home
to be close to my family and do
something I love so honestly I didn't
think that far ahead into it I just kept
doing something I loved and I've
developed a great team in the process
and friendships and and family through
it but Jennifer guess what you were
still taking on the world yeah and I
love your advice buy those sneakers and
wear those sneakers don't just put them
in the box and keep them fresh and
pristine they're for wearing Jennifer I
wear a size 10. thank you so much for
coming we're glad to have you here Bravo
congratulations cheering you on